hace 30 años cecilia maras y decidió
abortar cuando me entero que usted
embarazada no tuve ningún tipo de duda
una duda en embarazo había sido
resultado de una violación y como ocurre
en muchos casos por una mezcla de
desconocimiento y el estigma que
acompaña al aborto recurrió a la
clandestinidad había una camilla en la
medida de un montón de libros todos
sucios
las preguntas antes de que la anestesia
tome efecto era
tremendas
me asustaron más que el aborto así
dónde estás alguien te vio nos recuerda
en la dirección
no cuentes a nadie que viniste acá quién
te está esperando abajo y al día
siguiente me tuve que ir a inaugurar me
desmayé me salí me caí del colectivo
pues no podía avisar que vivir por eso
con una hemorragia tremenda
historias como estas que cientos de
mujeres salieron a celebrar frente al
congreso el día en que el presidente
alberto fernández envió al legislativo
un proyecto para legalizar el aborto y
evitar la clandestinidad una
clandestinidad que implica además cargas
legales y sociales aún cuando sea pocas
condenas firmes por aborto efectivamente
lo que hay son pocas condenas lo que no
significa que no haya todo un aparato y
todo un sistema puesto a perseguir
mujeres por hechos de aborto es todo un
sistema que se extiende también en
muchos casos al contexto más cercano de
la persona que decide abortar no me
arrepiento
pero esta gente muy llegada a mis amigos
me han dicho dios te va a castigar vas a
quedar estéril tus hijas van a nacer mal
si tus hijos van a nacer mal
a los 24 años tuve a mi primer hija
y estoy asustada hasta el momento clave
para que mujeres como sus hijas no deban
pasar por lo mismo que pasó ella cecilia
también lleva el pañuelo verde que usan
quienes quieren que cambie la ley